[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir je vous souhaite une bonne année
2010 9 plein de sortie tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 10 janvier
l'association multisons de
voisins-le-bretonneux fait son premier
tous en scène de l'année
des musiciens amateurs se produit sur
scène accompagnés par des professionnels
la vice présidente de l'association sera
avec nous pour nous donner le rythme
le pôle culturel de rambouillet
accueille depuis le 5 décembre une
exposition cap là vous pouvez y
reconnaître de nombreux monuments et
même des locaux reportage à découvrir
dans cette édition les templiers
d'elancourt reviennent pour cette
nouvelle saison les joueurs joueront
leur premier match samedi et sont très
motivés à ne laisser aucun point à leurs
adversaires la lanterne de rambouillet
accueille des caps là jusqu'au 26
janvier le moment le monde en cap là à
présent des monuments emblématiques
européens et nationaux
patrick jacq de disques jacques de
dixmude à jouer à les reconnaître
[Musique]
le london bridge anglais la porte de
brandebourg allemande et même la mairie
de rambouillet la ressemblance est
frappante et impressionne les visiteurs
c'était vraiment très rigolo c'est de
voir les la réaction des gens quand ils
passent la porte ils font tous la même
chose c'est-à-dire ils ont des yeux
vraiment écarquillés et c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant pour tout le monde
de voir ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire la
lanterne souhaité une exposition ludique
et interactive
elle a été séduite par la proposition du
centre cap là l'exposition a été montée
à l'aide des scolaires de la ville et
s'est ouverte le 5 décembre
un vrai succès environ 300 visiteurs se
rendent au pôle culturel chaque ses blu
ray sony par la tour de pise heures pas
mal comme moi elle tient quoi le fait de
quelques chaînes sans corde aussi en
plus de la visite les enfants peuvent
s'essayer à leur propre construction
avec des ateliers gratuits animés par
des membres du centre cap là c'est bien
il respecte bien et des voix fait un peu
dur mais j'y arrive bien au vu du succès
du monde en cap là la lanterne recherche
déjà une nouvelle exposition pour sa
saison 2019 2020 au moins une exposition
dans le style ça peut être un style
artistique différent mais ce que je veux
dire c'est avec un objectif de
participation de la population et
et vraiment un objectif de rassembler
les différents agents fait notamment les
enfants et des jeunes vous avez jusqu'au
26 janvier pour reconnaître la sagrada
familia de barcelone
et encore le port de copenhague et si
vous êtes bien trop énergiques pour des
constructions de kapla en équilibre
l'association multisons vous propose de
venir vous déhancher à la salle de la
tour de voisins-le-bretonneux ce
dimanche 13 janvier avec nous un plateau
julie vous êtes président de
l'association bonjour alors quel est le
principe de cet après midi musical
s'appelle tous en scène
l'après midi va se décomposer en quatre
moments effectivement il y aura le
projet tous en scène qui va accueillir
donc des adhérents qui auront répété
pendant un trimestre douze morceaux 12
12 reprises sur des tonalités pop rock
pour des instruments donc c'est basse
batterie guitare claviers chant
il y aura deux groupes partenaires qui
vont également qui seront présents
dimanche insolation et chercher ailleurs
toujours sur pop rock grunge et puis le
groupe en scène
qui refait son apparition au chai
multisons donc quand vous dites des
groupes partenaires c'est des groupes
qui appartiennent à l'association ce
sont des groupes qui sont adhérents
d'associations et on leur propose des
scènes dans l'année à voisins le
bretonneux montigny enfin des scènes
locales en tout cas alors justement tous
en scène c'est un concept que vous
faites depuis plusieurs années mais ça
fait partie des nombreuses activités de
l'association c'est assez large
finalement oui tout à fait l'idée c'est
vraiment d'accompagner les musiciens
dans une pratique amateur tous niveaux
de néophytes à confirmer
donc en leur proposant des scènes on les
coaches ans avec des professionnels de
la musique
et puis en les faisant accéder un
tremplin
ce qu'on fait depuis quatre aliments la
différence c'est que là c'est la musique
un peu plus libre par rapport au
conservatoire mais ya pas de solfège de
la pratique absolument tout à fait même
un néophyte qui qui commence son
instrument dès le début d'année peu au
bout d'un trimestre pour tous en scène
montée sur scène et à travers un groupe
éphémère jouer un morceau c'est pour
commencer dès le début sur scène pour se
faire plaisir donc cette année c'est
aussi le retour de groupes en scène où
l'avait évoqué tout à l'heure c'est quoi
groupe en scène groupe en scène ce sont
des musiciens un peu plus confirmé
souvent issus de tous en scène qui ont
envie de plus d'autonomie ils vont être
coaché une heure par semaine par des
professionnels du monde de la musique
pour les aider à mieux monter un morceau
travailler certaines parties etc
vous nous donnez un autre rendez vous
c'est au mois de mars avec la 4ème
édition du tremplin rock absolument lui
c'est effectivement la quatrième édition
du tremplin rock on accueille quatre à
cinq groupes
l'idée c'est vraiment de dévoiler de
nouveaux talents de la scène locale
donc rendez vous au mois de mars le 17
et justement ce dimanche pour tous en
scène au niveau ma vie dit il ya
quelqu'un d'umaga aussi un groupe du
tremplin rock qui sera présent oui des
membres de chercher ailleurs ou
participer à un des tremplins un des
précédents tremplin dont car il ya du
bon niveau du bon niveau donc tout ça ça
se passe ce dimanche à 15 heures à la
salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations sur
l'association sur le site internet
merci joly d'être bien visible sur notre
plateau et on donne rendez vous au plus
de monde possible à dimanche c'est ça
absolument rendez vous dimanche en
famille on aime avec des amis très bien
on passait la suite si j'arrive à
trouver mes feuilles
pas du tout on reste dans l'univers
musical d'ailleurs avec l'association
versaillaise balançoire samedi 12
janvier vous pouvez apprendre la danse
coquidé à la maison de quartier de
porchefontaine dans l'après midi puis
vous rendre au bal folklorique le soir
les trios baladins le trio baladins
animera la soirée à la salle de la voa
versailles
toujours à versailles le théâtre
montansier accueille depuis le 8 janvier
et jusqu'à ce dimanche 13 l'une des
célèbres pièces de molière le tartuffe
sur les planches vous retrouverez pierre
arditi jacques weber et encore isabelle
gélinas dans une mise en scène de peter
stein
cette création est une coproduction du
théâtre montansier et des planches à la
toile pour votre rendez vous dans les
salles pâtre jacques de dixmude s'est
rendu au ciné cette d'elancourt pour
retrouver cyrano de bergerac et françois
vidocq
[Musique]
cette semaine aussi les sept plein de
très bons films bon aux habitudes ont
des salaires mais cette semaine une
sortie nationale
et nous donc qui est une adaptation
d'une pièce de théâtre qui raconte la
jeunesse de cyrano de bergerac
c'est très très drôle savons rouge et ça
raconte vraiment l'histoire de
l'écriture de la pièce et cetera donc
que tous ceux qui s'intéressent à cyrano
de bergerac et ils sont nombreux
n'hésitez pas à venir découvrir ce film
dans nos salles et ensuite une petite
sélection de très bons films aussi de
vous proposons wild life avec jake
gyllenhaal qui est un très joli film
la palme d'or du festival de cannes le
film chinois une affaire de famille en
vf et en vo je précise que nous propose
aussi cette semaine
l'empereur de paris de jean françois
richet avec vincent cassel et amanda le
très joli film avec vincent lacoste qui
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui
vit sa vie jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
confrontés à la mort de sa soeur et à
l'obligation dû s'occuper de sa petite
nièce et je ne voulais pas finir sans
vous parler du phénomène actuel bohemian
rhapsody qu'il faut absolument venir
voir en salles nous l'avons toujours
nous vous proposons en version originale
et version française
le film fait déjà fait quatre millions
d'entrées et j'ai appris hier soir en
écoutant la radio que la bande originale
du film cartonnait aussi dans les bacs
des disquaires et
quinn est en tête des ventes de disques
c'est qui est une très bonne nouvelle
c'est grâce au film donc venez voir
l'histoire de ce grand chanteur et grand
artiste qu'était freddie mercury dans
nos salles cette semaine et templiers
d'elancourt reprennent du service après
leur défaite en demi finale contre les
corsaires d'evry la saison dernière
l'équipe compte retenir la leçon avec
pour objectif la montée en première
division pour les aider de nouveaux
joueurs rentrent dans l'effectif
notamment alexandre sa sonde qui revient
dans son club de formation
samedi ils affronteront les pionniers de
touraine à domicile au complexe sportif
europe pour cette première journée de
deuxième division et joueur invité sur
le plateau du 7-8 sport de michael et
miteux rollin 17 janvier se sont montrés
plutôt confiant donc on a le niveau
on sait on a l'effectif on a les jeux
pour on a travaillé à l'entraînement
maintenant falloir qu'on soit qu'on
reste discipliné et comprennent notre
défaite contre les cancers l'année
dernière en demi-finale où l'ont mené à
bien le score en première mi temps et on
s'est fait remonter en deuxième comme le
sont et on va en prendre en mairie pour
le match de samedi également beaucoup de
rugby ce week end dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 plaisir reçoit le stade
gennevillois pour la 13e journée le
plaisir rugby club est actuellement 10e
de sa poule au classement et n'a que
trois points d'avancé sur la première
équipe en zone de relégation dans le
championnat honneur le sky rugby rugby
reçoit dans son stade du bout des clos à
maurepas l'équipe de melun objectif top
5 pour les joueurs du sky rugby
actuellement classé 6e
pour notre escapade en dehors des terres
yvelinoise nous partons dans l'univers
des bulles
[Musique]
riad sattouf l'auteur de bd connu pour
ses albums l'arabe du futur et les
cahiers d'esther exposé planches
originales et croquis à la bibliothèque
publique d'information du centre
pompidou reportage de nicolas le
herissier de nos confrères via grand
paris ces dessins ont déjà séduit des
milliers de lecteurs pour la première
fois une exposition est consacrée au
dessinateur riad sattouf planches
originales croquis extraits de films
l'exposition met en lumière l'univers de
cet artiste prolifique entre les cahiers
d'esther et l'arabe du futur riad
sattouf est devenue en quelques temps un
auteur majeur de bande dessinée
l'une des caractéristiques de du travail
de riad sattouf c'est ce qui nous a
permis d'affirmer ce sous titre
l'écriture dessinée c'est qu'il tient à
la fois le texte et le dessin
en même temps il les composent ces
textes et il compose ses dessins en même
temps et comme on peut le voir dans
l'exposition
il écrit lui-même en fait une matrice
qu'on appelle un story board qui va
comporter et tenir à la fois et en même
temps ces deux aspects finalement de son
récit sa bande dessinée phare l'arabe du
futur est un vrai succès à chaque
parution inspiré de sa propre histoire
elle raconte la vie d'un jeune garçon
grandissant entre la syrie d'hafez al
assad et la bretagne de ses grands
parents un récit autobiographique qui a
séduit un large public
traduit en plus de vingt langues l'arabe
du futur a déjà été décliné en quatre
tomes
c'est un récit qui retrace son enfance
et son adolescence entre l'orient et
l'occident et puis surtout c'est un
récit universel puisque à l'intérieur de
son sort et si finalement il porte un
souci et on va dire un thème majeur
qui est un thème qui nous concerne tout
ce qui est finalement comment devient
ton grand comment finalement se
construit ton quel que soit
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue
par rapport à la cellule familiale par
rapport aux failles ou aux défaillances
de la cellule familiale
une exposition gratuite à découvrir sans
plus attendre jusqu'au 11 mars
c'est la fin de votre cette ut wazir
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles idées sorties
m
[Musique]
oh
m